il ne reste plus rien de cet appartement
totalement dévasté par l'explosion et
l'incendié qui s'en est suivi c'est hier
en fin d'après midi à 17h30 dans cet
immeuble avenue des rep à vesoul que le
drame s'est déroulé à notre arrivée les
pompiers sont confrontés à un violent
feu d'appartement et ils ont réalisé le
sauvetage d'une personne et ainsi que la
mise en sécurité de quatre autres alors
sur place ont été engagés une bonne
dizaine d'engins
ce qui représente à peu près 35 sapeurs
pompiers deux personnes sont blessées
très gravement elles ont été
transportées sur le centre hospitalier
une plus légèrement incommodés par les
fumées a été également transporté sur le
centre hospitalier
très vite sur place les pompiers
policiers sont rejoints par des agents
de l'électricité et du gaz
il faut sécuriser la zone les autres
locataires sont évacués et c'est
véritablement un drame humain qui serait
la cause de cette explosion
une dispute conjugale qui aurait mal
tourné on savait que ce couple ne
s'entendait pas qu'il y avait souvent
des discussions violente entre eux et là
on se rend compte que malheureusement
ces tentatives de suicide de du
compagnon et sa compagne était juste à
côté de lui elle était la première
victime de cette explosion
puisque ce cette substance inflammable
s'est enflammée très vite elle a
provoqué une onde de choc dans tout
l'immeuble
la mairie de vesoul a organisé le
relogement des autres locataires dans
cet immeuble il y avait six logements
tous inhabitable pour le moment une
enquête est en cours et une cellule
psychologique a été mise en place